welcome back to the recruitment mentors
podcast i'm your host hisham azuz
and on this week's episode i was joined
by the first irishman
in the podcast studio and that is
anthony kelly who for the last two years
has been building a successful career at
trust in soda he's achieved four
promotions in four years
and in this episode we covered
everything we really dug deep into how
anthony has been able to
merge modern methods with old school
methods how he leverages meetups and
podcasts to build his name build his
client base
how he went from building a market
entirely from scratch
to building the team of the year the
team of the quarter
and many other achievements
if you're someone that's aspiring to be
the top performer within your company
this year you have to listen to this
episode enjoy
anthony welcome to the podcast asian
great uh great to be here great to
finally meet you i know i was saying you
are the first irishman to take a seat in
the studio proud moment for you
absolutely
first time you met after about i think
14 months now yeah we've been we've
known each other for a little while
haven't we obviously um got involved
with recruitment mentors the learning
platform got to know each other a bit
there and yeah i've i've been really
looking forward to sitting down with you
i think obviously you dropped me a
couple of nudges to say like hey look
when am i getting my call up i think the
last one was obviously a great
achievement last year being the top
former globally in on the perm side of
things intra novo and uh yeah was was
really looking forward to sit down with
you so
there's a lot that we're going to go
over i think we're just saying before
definitely going to have a real focus in
the last two years because i think it's
fair to say that's where you've had some
real exponential growth in in your
career
and um but we'll touch on just early
days learnings looking back but we'll
mainly focus on the last two years so
i guess where i always like to start
is i'd love to get your thoughts on what
you believe are the common
characteristics and traits of a
successful modern day recruiter in your
view and then we'll kick it off there
good yeah i'll um i'll try and go for
the ones that
people don't generally give you know
people will always tell you you got to
be able to
take the hoys and the lows and come back
at it and actually say
hard-working when you get like new jobs
on and if you get a new job on a
half-five and if you're out the door at
six o'clock and if it's exclusive job or
even if it's not an exclusive job you're
probably not going to fill it you need
to be able to put the hours in when
necessary don't say i don't mean you to
do it every day when it matters to be
able to do it
and then i'm going to say something
that's i don't know a lot of people
would say but i'd say courageousness
courageousness courageousness in the
sense that
yeah do a podcast do a meet up do a blog
do something different to get your name
out there do the stuff that makes you
uncomfortable and to build your brand
because i think that's
that's a mixture of you know hard work
and something older courageousness
something a little bit about that so
work ethic is that something that you
believe you've always had something that
you grew up with you were surrounded by
that's all i have really
where that where's that come from you
know i don't know i think i had my
fourth job when i was 14 years old
really i worked in a nightclub uh
hanging at 14.
in a cloak room i worked there up until
i was 22. wow but even in between then i
used to summer holidays work on a
building site doing labor
and then other weekends my uncle's best
friend owned his own his own clothing
store and i used to work at the shop
floor while still being in the nightclub
on weekends
so you've already so you worked from an
early age yeah yeah i love that so
if we're just to touch on the sort of
early days when when would you say your
career truly started then was it when
you got into recruitment at s3 was it
before that what would you say for us to
tell you uh to put it aside i got into
recruitment when i was 22. when i was 21
i got sacked from landows
21. what for what did you get for i gave
my friends and family discount
without management approval
so to say there was a career glow up
after getting let go fernando's wouldn't
do it justice
i love that okay cool so how did um
there's always normally a story how did
you end up going from nando's in that
experience to working for s3 um so i
actually went from from nando's i was
trying to find jobs um
and i spent like my last bit of money to
try and get interviews everywhere
i'm getting a suit
and i was getting off i couldn't get an
interview because i was young
no education like i've used caller i
think as a gcse's i failed those
dropped out of community college yeah i
got sat from nando's
pretty unemployable
at the age of 21 and then uh i got a job
in the call center okay
and i was there maybe like
14 months and then 40 minutes was your
first proper office yeah yeah and in 14
months i went from being like you you
know what you're selling what you said
was it sales yeah white papers
would you mean like you would paper no
white papers uh-huh like information
sheets about emergencies
yeah basically like publications digital
publications kind of like lead
generation okay ish and then it would go
to like ibm or dell to try and sell to
the person i spoke to really strange i
actually don't know how that industry
still makes money after
so long yeah but it's it's a successful
industry and i went there i was there 14
months but like after six months i was
made like trainee team leader to team
leader
um
so just really applaud yourself yeah
yeah took a lot of hours again you're
talking
70 80 hour weeks saturdays and sundays
i'd be in for when the uh
west coast east coast of the us would
open and i'd finish when the west coast
closes oh wow yeah so it was um tough
industry
and then i got uh i'm sure you probably
even know in burka acer used to be on
esri's uh talent acquisition
he messaged me and said hey would you be
interested in recruitment i was like nah
it sounds like a ponzi scheme
and then i had a really bad day at work
on there and i messed up goes hey is
this recruitment thing still going yeah
yeah and then that was it i went for an
interview and there we go joined uh
joined s3 and then what what would you
say
what's the career and recruitment giving
you that maybe you least expected i
always like to ask that question for me
i would say the biggest thing that it
gave me is a level of communication
skills that i never had the way you can
interpret situations the way you can
speak to people
a level of calm calmness when
you know general situation should be
high pressure i mean if you can have you
know six dropouts in six in six weeks
it's pretty hard to get stressed after
that um but yeah i would say those sort
of characteristics being not even be
more personable but just being more
actual
being able to listen to people a lot
better
um and i think that really goes goes a
long way and i say this because these
are like skills that i was traditionally
really bad with really bad when i was
younger i used to be very i suppose
selfish
and used to be like yeah so i i used to
have a bit of a bravado that wouldn't
have been very uh very nice
and i appreciate you sharing that i
think that's such a
interesting point i think you mean
obviously i'm sure you see it now in
your management career but being able to
effectively communicate
is just such a valuable skill
not necessarily just in a sales
environment but just in life in general
so i think that's really interesting
that that's something that yeah maybe
it's really given you and equipped you
with that clearly it wasn't something he
was really strong at before that
how would you describe your first year
in recruitment was it
difficult
yeah it was it was it was tough in the
sense that it was
time consuming you know i joined uh
s3 there was like 12 of us 12 chinese
joining at once and now look i remember
looking back
we are all there for nine months and
over the nine months i build more than
all 11 of them put together really i am
but i was there every day you know seven
or eight out pulling my own business i
was like a whole school i was picking up
i was like hey can i get air can i get a
budget i want to just walk by this
company's office and drop them in
coffees and dinners
i was like because i've not got a busy
day today so i'm gonna make myself busy
but i think like they were very
supportive and willing to do that
but i mean other than that i mean i
would say i would say i really enjoyed
it um
yeah just found yourself an environment
where
basically if you really applied yourself
you got rewarded yeah yeah normally if
obviously you're doing the right things
and learning from maybe challenges
mistakes but a lot of people say who
i've had on here that
were part of that s3 culture period
really talk highly of the training the
development curious like what what would
you say you sort of still live by now or
use today that maybe you learnt really
early on in your recruitment crew out of
interest yeah a couple of things um it
would be that one as well having a
reason to drop into someone if
you can't speak to them and you're
somehow passing their office
have a reason to drop in
um
something that i was that was really
helpful i think it was rachel kelly that
showed me this really well rachel kelly
was probably the best mentor i've had
when it came to learning in computer
futures
yeah s3 she's been there like 18 years
she's won like top builder uk in ireland
um for
say like 14 of those 18 years wow
unbelievable shows the dot net market in
ireland
rachel if you're listening we need to
get on the pod
she has that she has that like down down
okay
i wouldn't even bother setting up a
competition really okay so she was a
great mentor yeah yeah even so much to
like if you were to work very close to
her clients she would make sure that
you're working to her standard okay very
specifically and
the way maybe this is the way i took it
you know she'd be very brutally honest
and what you've done bad and then very
complimentary what you've done well and
then she'd split the difference and like
this is what you're doing well this is
what you're doing bad i'm to an extent
that like if i was sending over a cv to
a client i'd have to send it to horror
force for horde to say okay why are you
saying this candidates on this that's
not really relevant to this can you tell
me this like everything from that great
now you've got that candidate in
interview
how are you going to prepare them what
notes have you got for them you're
debriefing them what notes can you get
from them on the debrief that you can
give to the next candidate going in for
prep and she taught me basically to
really good qualifications to really go
preps to really good debriefs and
recycling all that information back to
give to the next person to basically
increase your percentage of chance of
placement at that point again
yeah that's interesting so that's
something that's really stuck with you
yeah yeah and it's something that i know
you're training on to everyone within my
business in my teams you can see it like
sucky for example he has that we have a
client and he was like i
i know what i sent him he forced new job
sent in his first five candidates he was
like yeah they all failed he was like
boy he's been building up his fourth
round interview question since and now
everyone that goes in just passes the
forest yeah
okay so he knows that though he really
he knows that's the story and that's why
yeah okay i love that so obviously we
touched on i guess a bit early days i
guess
like obviously i was saying earlier a
couple of sort of achievements tonight
before we move in on to the last
two years but obviously he was a
from what i remember she was at s3 for
nearly three years right yeah like you
said joined in a group of people but one
of the things that you had in your
linkedin profile was yeah it was in the
the top two top three console in ashrae
uk all in one year in 2017. i guess
you're just curious to get your thoughts
on and then we'll move on to the last
two years like that that's a great
achievement right would have been a
really competitive environment
internally so like what would you say
looking back were some of the other
standards that you live by or principles
that you think you really took on board
live by day in day out that really
enabled you to achieve those
achievements you think
yeah um i suppose what i would say what
made my time different like in my second
year i won best newcomer rookie which
was people between 13 to 14 months um
and halfway through the year i was like
i'm going to win i'm going to win it
halfway two years like 80k off the pace
really and this is what i would say was
from that moment to like the end of the
next year it just really
kicked on like i was doing
three four placements a month
consistently
for like a year and a half well
like to the extent that i was made like
60 70 placements in a year and a half it
was a low fees market but it's still
when i said low fees if it's consistency
that's that's 10k yeah which uh still
pretty decent
what i would say like what what i'd done
differently is as i stopped saying hello
computer futures anthony speaker i
started saying hey how you doing it's
anto
yeah yeah cause that's that's what my
friends call me and i think that level
of personability
just came true and fed through to my
candidates when i was asking them a
available for a follow-up it gave me
like a different element of like
candidate control i was meeting everyone
video calling everyone if they were
abroad but i was antho it wasn't anthony
even though like s3 itself was really
professional i i made me very personable
um and i think that gave me just like so
much benefits out of it i can't exactly
say what it is but it just
changed everything you really yeah you
you
you really brought your authentic self
yeah yeah every interaction relationship
what do you think
interested because i'm sure this is
something you maybe help people with now
and maybe the environment you're in now
at soda it's a bit more
from what i from the people i've met and
what i know about the brand might be a
bit more free reign to bring that to
work but i guess
what what do you think maybe held you
back i don't want to say i held you back
but why do you think it took that long
for you to to bring ampho to the to to
the to work life or take that approach
you think esther you used to have to
wear suits and shorts and toys it was
it was it was just that that simple you
know there was no uh
like if it was a sunny day
25 degrees outside we're all in the
office an old victorian building
roasting you have to get an email from
the director to say yeah you can take
your toys off even even if you're not at
a client meeting there's no clients
coming into your office it's just 50
people on one floor you know so i think
that comes back to courageousness right
that you use courageousness to i'm
assuming you didn't go in now walking
with flip-flops and shorts
but like you you made the decision was
like you know what i'm gonna really
bring myself to work and be myself and
you then obviously saw the rewards of
that people brought into you that
authentic authenticity yeah i find that
so interesting so let's talk about the
the last two years then because we're
saying just to frame this up obviously
an amazing uh achievement last year 2021
obviously top perm consultant across the
group i mean there's there's a good
amount of people that's against right
yeah yeah yeah do you know exactly
um
four thousand i think it wasn't her
really okay love that so
um
like let's just let's just frame this up
because i think obviously you were
saying to me it was your best year right
best year buildings wise what what did
you finish last year on but it was like
610 612.
enough better you've ever had yeah and
obviously the the important context here
for people listening is that's also a
period where at this beginning of the
year you it was just it was just you
and then by the end of the year
you was at six people you were building
an embedding manager role six people in
your team and then you now got eight
people in your team in the middle of
obviously the this 2022. yeah i think
the thing i like about the most though
is six months before me joining then
soda had never touched an ai or data
client in germany ever so there was zero
candidates and zero clients and zero
businesses from the day i started yeah
that's nuts
that's you should be proud of that i'm
very proud of it yeah so let
let's unpack this then so i guess why
don't we why don't we first start then i
guess towards the beginning
and with what you just shared there why
don't we just talk a bit about what was
the game plan for you to to go to the
german market do those particular niches
that you're going to focus on what what
was the the approach that gave you
confidence it was going to work or
things were going to work like talk to
us about the early period and what what
the game plan was yeah so i guess sort
of
when i when i was joining initially i
was telling dave ash and ollie yeah i'm
going to do
data and ai which obviously is a big
paradigm
goes into that you know it's a big
pillar that like we can build this out
and make a lot of places here
and then like a week in or like three or
four days you know i goes no i've i've
changed my mind can i do computer vision
i was like self-driving cars
self-checkouts all video related camera
based technology
ali just said he's like i've no idea
what it is but if you think it can work
uh i'll back you just go ahead and do it
um so i spent two weeks without picking
up the phone two weeks about picking up
the phone just adding contacts and
businesses to try and understand who is
the companies to hire computer vision
where are they and then how can i start
to make connections with them so they
did all the legwork of like the market
mapping basically yeah yeah yeah and
just quickly now because this is really
common like if if i was in your team
tomorrow and we identified like a
particular niche what what like what
does market mapping actually mean is it
that i'm just going on linkedin i'm
looking at all the companies that have
this certain technology or certain thing
that i'm going to be focusing on then
i'm going to add the hiring managers and
i'm going to be trying to grow my
network candidates like what is that
marking what do you actually do in that
market mapping period well i guess
that's exactly it you want to find out
exactly every single company and what
technologies they use i was going
through
just searching computer vision berlin
like going through every single linkedin
search page
looking for candidates who had just
computer vision in it to see what
companies they were at because some
companies could be like four people big
right computer vision they're all
startups so you'd have to just find out
who had computer vision engineers
because if you look at it now there's
probably
like over the last 90 days 400 computer
vision charts posted on linkedin yes
it's growing and half of them are
probably from like big companies like
facebook so you take all them away about
50. so you weren't building a market
looking for looking for open jobs you
were being very proactive in who you can
get on i mean it paid its dividends i
mean sometimes i was getting business on
with companies where i made like three
or four placements where in a couple of
months they didn't even have a careers
page right so i was like my competition
definitely can't even why is that bigger
than part so important in your opinion
because a lot of people say that you
need to do that donkey work leg work
early on why is that so important
because if you try to do it while you're
working jobs recruiters like to work
jobs you get paid for filling jobs yeah
if you have even just one job to work
over admin or market mapping
you resource a job you'll speak to
candidates and you just won't do it as
well as it should
i think it sets the ground
for
if you want to do social selling you can
then mass market to the right type of
people um i mean i mean spending time
really trying to find out right email
addresses not just adding it for no
reason yeah like if i got a company that
i wanted to add i'd add everyone from
the executive assistant to like the
front desk to the sea levels to the
manager's full picture because i'm like
yeah
because no matter what i'm sharing on my
industry once it's about computer vision
everyone in this company is going to be
interested anyway
and you never know some of the times
i've had people come back you're like an
engineer or someone that wasn't
necessarily directly affected by lack of
iron but they were like oh i'll connect
you with this person
and then they'll connect you but then
they'll write back and you'd have
messaged that person 10 times before and
not have a response but a referral from
someone else in the business made a big
difference yeah so like i map
i tried to map every company as i can
and then also every person in those
companies and then just quickly on this
do you is this something that you go to
now you did that bigger than bit and
then is it something you make time for
throughout the year is it something you
look at on a monthly quarterly basis
just curious on that yeah i try to do
where um i try to
find new companies at least once or
twice a month probably you know one or
two hours
and then i know because because we know
a bit about each other i know like
you're so passionate about this the
niche piece right and and being known
for something and having a real focus
which you're talking about there
just really quickly before we go into
the sort of strategies and what's worked
and challenges
like what what sort of markers or
indicators got you really excited about
computer vision
like for you to go to turn around to
ollie and go look i know i said i was
going to do this
but i really want to focus on this like
what is it that you got excited about
what did you see i've gone from a market
with 50 000 vacancies to one with 50.
it's like yeah this makes perfect
business
um
it was actually when i was finishing up
my previous company covered was coming
in
and every larger enterprise who worked
with every large tech company every
company that i had or an internal talent
acquisition team or recruitment team
shut off the taps we're not using
agencies we're not using agencies
every computer vision company and i only
worked with one at the time but i was
able to bd and able to pick up two more
while no one else was hiring all
were all happy to work with me that's
because they're small companies they
didn't have hr departments you're like
you're contacting the people who are
directly affected
by not having the right person in there
which is cto if you're going to a 1 000
or a 500 person organization
cto is not worried about that
and then there's probably too many
barriers in between getting to the
person that is
true maybe they're like i'll go through
hr go to the hiring manager there's too
many blockers but within this you could
contact the c-level executive
who they need to spend vc money because
they have to make these hires because
they have to build a computer vision
product because if they don't build it
they lose their investors or they can't
go to the next round of funding okay
that's interesting hey everyone a real
quick one from me this podcast would not
be possible without our amazing podcast
partners vincerie and sauce breaker
because you listen to this podcast
you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're all a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincerie who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with sourcebreaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products
so let's first talk about
you as you sort of getting numbers on
the board building a name for yourself
making placements building that client
list and then we'll talk about
challenges that have come with like them
doing that whilst they're managing
leading a team and all of that so i
guess if you if you look at this
two-year period then what what's being
because i know you're quite passionate
about this i'm keen to get your thoughts
on it what what's been for you the most
effective way for you to get known liked
and trusted by the the companies that
you mapped out and that you were going
for so what's been your most effective
way of winning business winning clients
and and sort of unlocking that loyal
customer base that obviously loads of
recruiters aiming to do
yeah so i would say it's i can't pick
one sure but like obviously to say
social selling like when you come into a
market where you've got no
reputation whatsoever
and you want to just start talking to a
load of computer vision managers hey how
you doing i want to do computer vision
podcast can we talk i'd love to get your
honor
and you can speak to 20 managers in
three months that's 20 actual
relationships that you can try and
leverage into business
you do an event you can do the same
thing but then after you've made a
couple of placements and you've got a
decent little book there
you can start literally just picking up
the phone
hey
i see you're still advertising this job
can i help you no why not
it's like why not because i know that
there's not that many people doing my
market i'm like who he is using what's
going on i was like i can send you over
let us let us a recommendation i'm
working with like some companies of like
the guy i'm working with the company of
the guy who created computer vision oh
wow he's now got a new startup in berlin
and i'm hiring for them i just name drop
him and it's like if he's working with
me why won't you yeah yeah um
but then yeah there's a difference i can
use that to like maybe like a hr
a line manager and then you know maybe
next week i'm like oh he didn't like
that i last was when i come to my event
i didn't come back i'll ask you to come
to my podcast
hey here's this kill blogger bro yeah
just something all the time and i just
make it that uh
it was again a big reason why i picked
the niche market
i'd say there's probably
500 companies in the whole of germany
that i can contact or that would
actually hire in my space so i'm
probably targeting to hit them with some
kind of cv content or information
probably four to six times per month
okay so it's all relevant yeah yeah so
just to break that down a bit because
you mentioned social selling right so
how so like you said i think that that's
the key part to take away from that
there's like if you're listening to this
and you're relying on
one method one approach
for you to grow your sort of loyal
customer base you're gonna struggle
right and i feel like that's what that's
what you're saying here so like just
talk talk to us through like so right
now what are the sort of multiple ways
that you mentioned a few of them but
just to be clear what are some of the
the multiple ways that you would view
help you grow that log customer base so
you said obviously a podcast something
that you started you got an events event
a lot of events that you run you
mentioned like blogs actual industry
content and then you said cvs so like
just just i guess just talk us a bit
about that high level and on the
different ways and why that is important
and then we'll move on because i think
that's the key learning for people so
podcasts again i mean if you can come
across and do and deliver a very good
podcast with someone technical cto
lawyer manager
you're going to come across as their
go-to guy you know or girl whatever it's
going to be
next time they have a vacancy they'll
come back to you yeah i mean
those can be the longer term games you
know you can check them out they don't
have vacancies you can ask them how the
hiring is you can always have them
conversations but i would say 80 to 90
percent of the time
they'll ask you two weeks before they
know whatever they can see hey do you
have any idea what salary i should be
paying or if this was to come out would
you be able to help us
of course it would um
and then it's the same with the events
but
the events obviously is very much
they can be quite hard because they're
trying to get people in from speakers
yeah or from an event
into like conversion but when it happens
you actually have a very lot very little
one-to-one time with them
but it can always be used as another one
hey
let's do the event but let's book a
meeting up after let's see how
everything went and then you can look to
convert then
um
and then information cvs they're like a
little bit more quicker wins sometimes
you don't get the long-term relationship
out of them that you want sometimes they
can be
a quick a quick snatch deal even though
you know you could do a lot more with
them
some people are just not some people are
just interested in in a quick placement
and that's all they want you for yeah um
but i guess it's i guess it's about
having
having different arrows for your bow
uh different weapons that you can use
depending on on who it's going to be
that you're working with yeah and like
you said that enables you to build a
short-term relationship short-term
opportunities long-term opportunities so
i guess this was something that and i
know again something that we spoke about
just on the on this topic and it's
something also that um
ollie drop me a note about as well so i
think and this is what we spoke about so
i think when i spoke to a few of your
colleagues they all sort of spoke really
highly of you in the sense of like your
approach to business development and i
think that the the overarching thing
that i took and when we sort of prepared
for this was this sort of combining
social selling modern approach with old
school methods right and i know we're
talking about talking a bit about this
now but i guess how would you sum up or
describe that you use things like
podcasts meetups modern approaches
combined with old school getting on the
phone making things happen like how how
would you describe that you you combine
those
yeah um i mean look it gives you a
fantastic reputation when you pick up
the phone to someone who is a computer
vision manager or someone who hires in
computer vision when they look at your
linkedin like my linkedin looks
pretty pretty decent
you know you can see it's very well
accomplished you can see the
recommendations of ex guests you can see
lists and lists of people that have been
there
i think it creates like people seeing
your face either at a meet up at an
event people hearing your voice at a
podcast reduces you being a stranger
calling them for that first time
you know whereas every other time you're
just that same old recruiter trying to
send them a cv
trying to make a placement and trying to
leave them whereas these people have
probably heard seen spoken seen like so
many things
five or six times before
and and i think that's a nice way to get
in and get some long-term business but
then there's obviously you know some
people are not interested in these
podcasts and meetups
they're the people that you know you
sometimes you just have to make those
calls to
i'm pretty sure that like
i don't let people say that they won't
speak to me if they say they're not
interested in working with me as a
recruiter i'm like that's fine i goes
what about coming to one of my events so
on my on my podcast it's like these are
very relevant to you in your industry as
a minimum have you considered looking at
these i've never heard of them oh cool
why not it's like i know i know
everything that's going on in your space
in germany this is what i do i share
this information why don't you want to
know what's going on and then from them
nearly going to hang up the phone so
it's like what do you mean
what is it that you do actually
and then it's great so you know
i'm not afraid to to get told no
for anything because if someone says no
for walking i'm like oh great fallback
how about this yeah what about this it
sounds like you've been really proactive
you're picking up the phone okay cool
gullet so i want to segue into your
leadership journey because i know that's
really challenging for people and it
seems like you've made that a success
but i guess before i do um
people actually know well i was going to
ask you about like your day plan and how
you approach that because people always
love that but you know what actually
let's do let's do that when we're also
talking about you managing a leading
people because i think that that would
be really interesting with people and
like how you were able to build that
whilst also growing your team and how
you how you manage that so we'll touch
on that but i guess look we've kept it
quite positive what would you say
last year as you're growing your team
what was the most difficult part about
it about sort of keeping that
performance high
obviously making you could probably
sense that you was on track to have like
a really good year but then you wanted
to grow your team get the right people
in what were the maybe the challenges
last year that maybe you least expected
or came with that transition to
management um do you know what i would
actually say the challenges are coming
now okay more so than i should talk
about that
last year
it was like as soon as the team joined
everyone came together we went from one
to five overnight and it was like
everyone was just in flow state like
everything just happened like month two
full house montreal team full house i
was like this is this is unbelievable
there was like a trainee on my team who
done three deals in her first year
it was all going to play it was just she
was signing terms it was just like this
is
this is great
i was like i was having some of my best
months and yeah it just worked out
really well
whereas now there's
just me in seven so there's a team of a
my time has gotten
very much restricted now we're
trying to help like sookie is doing his
event yeah his first in-person event now
next week
this week
it's this week the eight it is it's this
week yeah yeah so sookie is doing his
first event so i'm going over for his
event
um and then two weeks and back over from
my event so i'm finding that
juggling all of that it's a lot of over
commitment and then trying to make sure
i've enough time for everyone and i mean
having enough time for five people when
a lot of the time you were able to be
remote working anyway now you're
struggling travel times and yeah it's
just being just being that quite a bit
stretched so how do you how are you
approaching at the moment like what's
the current approach to it because i
know it's not perfect yeah how are you
thinking about the moment this will be
helpful for people because this will be
a really typical journey that billing
managers go on so how are you currently
thinking about approaching those time
constraints and challenges and because
i'm sure you're thinking oh that person
on my team do they feel like i'm letting
them down do they feel like they're
getting enough support from me like how
are you currently thinking about
approaching it that you think is maybe
working well or yeah um
i would say i i sacrificed time speaking
the candidates okay more so than
speaking with my team interesting
everyone on my team has a consistent
one-to-one every month performance
management boy weekly training sessions
um
i speak to everyone on the team at least
once at least sometimes it might just be
a 30-minute session but you know some
people are in the team now one year
that's that's all they need that's all
they want they might just want to run to
you for 30 minutes yeah ahead there
could be people on the team that want or
need that little bit more support you
know maybe two 30-minute sessions per
week to talk about
their lnd where they're going to develop
um but with that as well i always make
sure that i'm booking out my own time
for
making sure i'm still doing bd
each week so that like if i if i come
into every week there's 20 hours gone
anyway that's between booking and bd and
toying with my team that's interesting
because
it's it's it's nice with a niche market
because also like if i sp if i get a
computer vision job on next week i'll
have 12 candidates in 24 hours and
that's unheard of in that market yeah
so i think choosing that niche has
allowed me to be able to spend less time
with candidates um it's kind of like a
java developer you need to do java you
don't it's the same with computers but
you've also got you've got you've got
now critical obviously is it just you
that does computer vision yeah yeah i
was going to say that you've then
obviously grown a bit of a team where
i'm sure that they do some obviously
they're building their candidate
networks and these things but that's
interesting so so the insight there i
got then is which i guess oftentimes can
slip for billing managers is your
non-negotiables each week beyond support
on the team as you every single week
you're showing up doing business
development
existing relationships new relationships
is something that you you always make
time for regardless yeah yeah and time
with the team yeah and time of the team
and then maybe it's the candidates that
you maybe don't have as much time but
you really work hard to build this
network so you know if you get these
grade a jobs that there's you know the
type of people that you want to be
calling that you could head on and speak
to
sometimes it's easier to win a new
business to get five cps five existing
cvs
then get four of new candidates for one
existing job what about what skill sets
have has anthony had to develop on this
journey so far what have you had to get
better at what things have you had to
learn the hard way when it comes to
i would say i would say
like it's the it's the doing and the
following up okay and not even that it's
the the process behind it something that
audi parity is actually amazing and i've
tried to replicate as much as i can so
you have your your team brief in the
morning monday morning and you let
everyone out
you tell everyone this is what we agreed
on here's our objectives here's our
goals here's our actions we'll catch up
these on these on wednesday let's see
how everyone's doing on wednesday and
then on wednesday you can link back to
the email that you sent on monday hey
how are you getting on based on
everything we agreed on and then again
same on friday and then reset in between
so what are you doing just an email
monday and then no follow up
but yeah
is that what you're doing i do i do i've
i've got good at it now i've got good at
the uh setting yeah setting the actions
the following up and even i mean you can
do that from a
one-to-one perspective a team weekly
objection setting perspective one like a
monthly one-to-one personal development
plan if you do a training session
everything has actions and objectives
after it that you're following up on
whereas previously i would have just
been like yeah here's i'm eating fine go
on
not know
like we agreed that was just there you
know um so the follow-up and the process
is something you've worked really hard
on yeah yeah so you had to become a lot
more organized
you know it was actually just being able
to manage to do that in time
with that so now i can do it while the
meeting's happening on a dual screen
whereas before i was like
drowning all the information coming in
yeah was all so new to me but yeah
okay balancing that was was quite nice i
think that was that was really good
anything else that you've really had to
work on learn
learn the hard way so you mentioned
obviously the process the follow-up from
a management leadership perspective is
there anything else that you've had to
get really good at do you think
i mean i haven't really had to deal with
much else it's just more so work with
everyone very closely performance manage
one-to-one
yeah nice
so i think this is we spoke about this
but this is something also ollie
mentioned
about and you you mentioned it to me
around he ollie really feels like you've
done a really good job of creating like
a mini culture in your team
um which he was saying that he feels
adds an additional purpose for people in
your team beyond working for the
overarching company and probably
something that
recruitment owners want their best
managers and leaders to do is that
they'll they'll sort of die and live for
the company but also their team manager
and in it within the team so i think
obviously you mentioned to me before we
uh called right that your team's called
the the cream team right team cream team
cream right crazy the cream rises to the
top
cream roses at the top obviously
ironically what's the idea behind this i
know you had a bit of a philosophy
around it but
why have you really intentionally built
this mini culture and really tried to
get people even further bought into what
you guys are trying to build as a
collective within the within the
business i can't remember the book
exactly it was in but it was definitely
one of the management framework books
and yeah as i was saying it was about
i can't even remember the coach now but
it was england's most successful
olympics coach
cycling or not no no over overall okay
so they get like an overall team coach
for everyone to go in right and everyone
like reports into him he's the team
leader
for 100 athletes to go over right
and
there is the thing that stops most teams
from being successful at the olympics
and i didn't know this until i read that
is illness illness yeah so they made
these things like let's be
the healthiest team
ever and then they called it like a
totem like a kind of like a ritual that
they all had to make sure that because
if one gets sick and you're all shared
in a house together so we're all going
to get sick so if you get sick you're
sacrificing that person's success and so
on like that so let's all agree we'll
wash our hands we'll sanitize our hands
before we enter every room and when we
leave
and there was a couple of little rules
like that and that was that was
their totem anyway it was the most
successful english olympics ever in
history even still to this date i was
like cool i was trying to think of that
so i can't get everything that inspired
you yeah you do a lot of do you
intentionally make time for you to learn
about how can you become a better leader
manager is that something you often do
yeah i would i would not so much
recently because i'm quite
i don't have the time as much now but i
do need that's not an excuse i need to
make time again but obviously when you
went on the journey it seems like he was
quite curious about it yeah yeah okay
cool so so you was inspired by that and
then what did you think what what can i
create what sort of rituals can i create
for for my team on the team that i'm
building yeah yeah and then um
i just came up i was like yeah look
let's
let's let's call ourselves team cream
because it was it was kind of like
joking at the time um because it was
when when the team had just set up and
like we'd been teaming them on team one
team and one team at a quarter like just
in like our first month i was like this
is this is unbelievable and then i just
written to like one of the chats yeah
the cream always rises to the top
and i was like yeah we're team cream and
then like from then it just it just
stuck but then what i've done is i took
it a step further and i do like a
three six months roll out of where were
we then where are we now
and basically like shown accountability
so like let's say like sucky who's now
gone into team leadership yeah like six
months ago we were rolling out i was
like yeah sookie wants to be here in six
to 12 months that means that as a team
we need to do this
but everyone there knows that if the
team doesn't do this it's actually
impacting possibly sucky's growth it's
impacting the growth of the potential
team
and we're getting people to buy into
that collective yeah so i don't think
people people often say in recruitment
oh what what am i here for am i just
here to generate revenue to make sales
and do business i'm like great yeah yes
you are um but in our team you doing
well you're doing well and the whole
team doing well here's how it affects
the person sitting beside you
um and we all got matching hoodies as
well yeah and you and you found people
really bought into that yeah yeah i love
that
so i guess as you come as we come to the
end here then what advice would you have
for people listen to to this that are
also on this billing manager journey may
be finding it really tough right now
they're in the the trenches of like i
don't know they've gone from like one
person that they're responsible for to
three to six now they're getting onto
the next stage like what advice would
you have to people that are on a similar
journey to you that might be helpful um
the structure the structure of when you
have a meeting there's an agenda
goals are set out and then after you're
following up what goals are set out
who's accountable for them
and how they're going to achieve that um
and then making sure you're following up
on that because if you're just setting
goals and you're not following up on
them
people aren't ever going to do
what their goals are anyway you know
they're not going to go
for their objectives if it's not
you might say yeah this is important but
then if you never follow up with them
how important is it yeah they say even
if it is important they start to think
oh it's not that important anyway he
never asks she never asks working on
your own time management um which again
i know is
he's a lot easier said than done but
with me i have you know blocked blocked
out times in my diaries which are
non-negotiables every week that
i either have for my team or for me to
do something whether it's from my desk
or or them specifically for my team and
and then team meetings
so let's just as you mentioned that
let's just break down what what a
typical day looks like for you then as
anthony the manager in a growing team
and then we'll wrap up what what does a
typical day look like then it's it's
more so typical week okay cool let's do
that let's do that so let's say if i say
typical week uh i'll have
we can start a week objective setting
midweek catch up friday end of the week
done so that's like team that's team
time group group team calls yeah there
is then individual time for every single
person on the team
for 20 minute sessions
probably
six to eight hours per week minimum yeah
maybe even a little bit at the beginning
of the week end of the week um mixed
mexicans monday tuesday tours day okay
trying to mix it up so i still have good
availability in court hours for myself
so i'm not sure honestly yeah the
objective setting the follow-up the sort
of wrap up the end of the week with the
team group staff then you've got
individual time 30 minute sessions with
the team
then what else do you have any other
team
to try no that would be unless there's
stuff coming up unless it's uh every
second week there's a team cream boy
weekly training session cream like that
yeah
and how long is that uh that'll be 45
minutes whatever lunch
end of the day on a wednesday and that
will be a topic that the team give to me
it's like what do you want to know about
whether it's interview preparation just
maybe current challenges they're going
through things they're interested in
yeah closing techniques stuff like that
every other week you've got a team cream
training session non-negotiable as well
yeah yeah and then i've got my
management calls that i'd have so there
might be
two or three hours per week maybe an
hour or two yeah
and then i do my traditional recruitment
stuff that i can even though i tell
everyone to do it there's not a lot of
people so you still see the owner four
hours of outbound bd every week two
hours of candidate regens every week
regens or something yeah it's just
regenerating candidates uh are all on
the database candidate somewhat spoke to
two years ago
um available what's going on yeah so for
four hours outbound client development
and two hours outbound uh candidate
development and
don't know what leads you get out of it
yeah someone you might have placed or
someone you might have not placed
there's now a higher manager i mean it's
or they're even even better yet they're
available i love that so and then any
other non-negotiables like activities so
you got four hours of that two hours of
that is anything else or is that that
would be it you know the rest of the
time is what i'd use for sourcing maybe
uh you know calls with new candidates
yeah i love that i love the
non-negotiables around that thanks for
sharing that so i guess to wrap up then
obviously we're halfway through
this year
what what have you got top of mind what
are you thinking about that is going to
make sure that the cream rises to the
top again at the end of this year yeah
yeah i'm uh i'm actually in the process
of of trying to place a whole team of
annoying people that were made redundant
oh wow uh-huh it should be unbelievable
yeah um
so if i do that i'll be very happy but
uh by the end of the year
ideally i'd have like you know setting
up in new regions munich switzerland um
this way we can really i guess the word
land and expand yeah you know we've got
a successful team in berlin
uh and you're all based on and don't
know your team
two in london five in dublin okay yeah
um in terms of that i think we're going
to be looking at our berlin office in q1
next year
um but yeah just really looking at
growth getting in that second line of
leadership so sucky obviously coming in
if i had my way i'd get one more team
lead um again that would be fantastic
for me because then i can spend more
time with sucky and new tv
and then with more people maybe let suki
manage two or three people but when it
really comes to performance manage i can
help out with that or and then how we
look in your own performance was we're
going to talk last year i think so hard
really we're going to try i'm going to
aim for it i'm not on track but this
month i'm going to feeling good i'm
going to have a six figure month month
yeah okay i love it anthony's been
absolute pleasure
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode